you said you have a dog yes what's your
dog's name
hazel why did you do that you look kind
of like a shoe like I remember there was
some angel that we've actually forgotten
and now whenever I'm in the park people
think I have Irish Tourette's listen he
has a trick I'm not need to see oh I
want to see this okay it all seems too
on-the-nose but this is I mean this is
something I discovered that he could do
on day when I was just watching TV
watching a show mm-hmm which will be
familiar with and the team chin came on
and this happened potato only only does
that when he hears the office theme song
the office theme song I've no idea why
there must be some noise in the music
not only buddy because when it first
started potato was looking down ears
twitching thinking and then it got to
the certain part of the song and oh yeah
there's maybe there's an you there must
be an instrument change in there
somewhere but it's amazing oh that's
such a sweet trick that's so amazing
that you found the one show either
potato loves or potato can't stand you
when your theme song comes on he doesn't
deform that's quite sweet like it's just
as regular yeah yeah I'm sure that means
it really loves the show that's my guess